well Austin I know you've been dreaming about
playing in the NHL since you were a little
kid in your wildest dreams though
did you see it unfolding like this
what a luminescent night for Austin
Matthews incredible four goals Mario
Lemieux now in the spotlight love you
his first shot on goal when he scores
Mario love you living up quickly
to all the advertisements [Music]
mix it up with unity soon to be the greatest
of my generation operation victory [Applause]
[Applause]
scores [Applause] welcome on board now
there's Jonathan tapes 19 years old
it is first NHL game what a debut
for Jonathan James [Music] [Applause]
oh my Conor Bedard puts on a show the Chicago
Blackhawks are very proud to select Connor Bedard
[Applause]